In the US, President Donald Trump...
...held a news conference to address the coronavirus pandemic...
...as he seeks to calm the nation.
In Brazil, President Jair Bolsonaro says he has tested negative for the new coronavirus,...
...after a scare over a trip in which at least one infected member of his staff...
...rubbed shoulders with Donald Trump.
US air strikes in Iraq targeted weapon storage sites of an Iranian-backed militia...
...in retaliation for a deadly attack on American and coalition troops 24 hours earlier.
In Canada, Prime Minister Justin Trudeau will be in isolation for two weeks...
...after his wife, Sophie Gregoire Trudeau, tested positive for coronavirus.
Finally from New Zealand, Prime Minister Jacinda Ardern joined the Muslim community in Christchurch...
...at a special joint prayer on the anniversary of the shooting that killed 51 people at two mosques.